and what about uh i'm dying to ask you
about
working with biggie smalls like when he
asked you to be on the what
did you have expectations of like where
his career was gonna go from there
no none of us did at that point you know
i think biggie was a bit more
locked in on where he wanted his career
to go but as far as me i
i was just rhyming i was doing what i
loved to do and just you know i wasn't
even
biding my time it was just that if it
goes it goes if it doesn't it doesn't
what
i mean i'll have something else to fall
back on but
being in the studio
with big i mean who wouldn't feel that
that aura of you know this this could be
something great when you're there and
you're doing the work and the work is
done and you're listening to the song
and
you know and you know who puffy is and
and the drive that he had and his
business savvy and
you see all this stuff coming to
fruition and to be a part of that is
like
it doesn't it doesn't hit you
until later on so you see it in
hindsight and you and you say to
yourself like man
i've done some things with some people
and i'm proud of the work
and that's and that's great right there
and i'll give a lot of love to tracy
waiples for um maneuvering and making
that happen because i wasn't even
supposed to do that record
oh what do you mean at that point in
time mutang like i said we had
all these labels working together for
our cause so
as far as doing records with other
people that's taking money
away from the clan and going over here
we didn't look at it so much as
all right we're gonna go over here and
take their fans and bring their fans
back because at that point in time like
i said we're all starting out
so everybody's fans are everybody's fans
everybody's
uh status is about the same so
you you don't really benefit from
working with other artists if you're
still trying to build your [ __ ] up to
superstar status
and um when big in them approach you
know rizzo was more or less like we
batting down the hatches we're not
giving anybody this work
unless i produce it
i so tracy waifus came and got me and i
went and did the biggie song and i'm
glad i did it
i had to do the same thing with the red
man song for um how high
so you know me sneaking off doing my
thing kind of helped it worked
yeah and that you're the only feature on
that whole ready to die album
yeah yeah yeah it's pretty pretty epic
here
and in hindsight you look at that and
and you say yeah i was the only feature
and then you think well well we started
at maybe he couldn't get any other
features
nah but i doubt that and like i said
honor very honored that you know
even um that we had a camaraderie
that um uh you know that we stood the
test of time and even through
the uh dilemma that was going on between
himself and
a few clan members at the time and stuff
you know we still held a
a good friendship yeah dude guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude